I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hi everyone. Hi. Lady, I want you to look at me. I am looking at you and the first thing I said when I sat down was, I love this top. What is this? I said I'm gonna bring it up. It is a sweatshirt. Uh-huh. But look, it has poofies. Poofy shoulders. Is that a hood? It's a poofy, shouldered, hooded sweatshirt. Remember, I told you these poofy things are
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。嗨。女士，我要你看着我。我正在看着你，我坐下时说的第一句话就是，我喜欢这件上衣。这是什么？我说我要提一下。这是一件运动衫。嗯哼。但是你看，它有蓬蓬的设计。蓬蓬的肩膀。那是连帽吗？这是一件有蓬蓬肩、带帽的运动衫。记住，我告诉过你这些蓬蓬的东西
back. This is true. Jenna went to the mall yesterday and she was texting me pictures of what I can only describe as Angela Martin's dream wardrobe. Yes, it's lacy, high neck, poofy shoulders, poofy arms. When we do our book tour, we're gonna be dressing this way. And I will also have, you know, speaking of our book tour wardrobe, remember, I said, I was gonna bring back the giant, like, cloth flower that I don't know why I have so many in my closet. It was a thing. I was watching Drew Barrymore's talk show last week. She was wearing one. No. I took a picture. What, on her blouse? Yeah, her shirt. She had a fakie flower. Oh, I need to see it. Mark my words. I am on trend. It's poofy sleeves
回来了。这是真的。珍娜昨天去了商场，她给我发了一些照片，我只能用安吉拉·马丁的梦想衣橱来形容。是的，蕾丝、高领、蓬蓬肩、蓬蓬袖。当我们进行新书巡回宣传时，我们会这样打扮。说到我们的巡回宣传服装，我还记得我说过，我要带回那个巨大的布花，我不知道为什么我的衣柜里有那么多。那曾经很流行。我上周在看德鲁·巴里摩尔的脱口秀。她戴着一个。不。我拍了张照片。什么，在她的衬衫上？对，她的衬衫。她戴了一朵假花。哦，我得看看。记住我的话。我走在潮流前沿。是蓬蓬袖
and fakie flowers. 2022, they're coming at ya. It's all happening, guys. Angela Martin fashion is here, mixed in with a little Jenna Fisher. A lot of people wrote in to say the fakie flower was from Sex and the City. I guess Carrie Bradshaw loved a fakie flower. She is not the OG of the fakie flower. Who is? I mean, I can't even tell you how much mail we got about it. I mean, I feel like fakie flower was here in the 80s. Let's look up some Molly Ringwald. Come on. I'm with you there. Yeah. I'm positive I had a fakie flower. I clipped on a hat because I was trying to be, like, was that movie pretty in pink? I have decided that I'm going to single-handedly bring back the fakie flower during our book
和假花。2022年，它们向你走来了。一切都在发生，伙计们。安吉拉·马丁的时尚来了，还混搭了一点珍娜·费舍的风格。很多人写信来说假花来自《欲望都市》。我猜凯莉·布拉德肖很喜欢假花。她可不是假花的鼻祖。那是谁？我是说，我甚至无法告诉你我们收到了多少关于它的邮件。我的意思是，我觉得假花在80年代就有了。让我们查查莫莉·林沃德的造型。来吧。我同意你的看法。是的。我肯定我有一朵假花。我把它别在帽子上，因为我当时想模仿，那是《粉红佳人》那部电影吗？我已经决定，我要在我们的新书巡回宣传期间
tour. Even though Drew Barrymore wore one on her show, I'm going to bring it wide in 2022. Bring it wide? Yeah, I am. That should be our book tour slogan. Bring it wide. No. You know what? Let's rethink that. We should not. You know what? I'm going to think on it. Okay. Bring your flower. No. Well, maybe. No. We'll see you on the book tour. But for today, we're going to be discussing Dream Team, which is season five, episode 20 of The Office written by BJ Novak and directed by Paul Feig. Let's have a summary. Here it is. Michael has officially left under Mifflin, and he has started his own paper company called Michael Scott Paper Company in his condo. Pam has joined him. Michael is having a little
单枪匹马地带回假花。尽管德鲁·巴里摩尔在她的节目中戴了一朵，但我要在2022年把它发扬光大。发扬光大？是的，我要这么做。那应该是我们的新书巡回宣传口号。发扬光大。不。你知道吗？让我们重新考虑一下。我们不应该那样做。你知道吗？我会考虑一下。好吧。带上你的花。不。嗯，也许吧。不。我们在新书巡回宣传时见。但今天，我们要讨论的是《梦之队》，这是《办公室》第五季第20集，由BJ·诺瓦克编剧，保罗·费格执导。让我们来个剧情摘要。在这里。迈克尔正式离开了邓德·米夫林，他在自己的公寓里创办了自己的造纸公司，叫迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。帕姆加入了他的行列。迈克尔在面对工作日时有点
trouble facing his workday, but with Pam's encouragement, he decides to assemble a Dream Team to get their company started, and they are also going to have a meeting with a potential investor. Things are looking up. Yeah. Meanwhile, back at the office, Charles is in charge. I know. In Scranton. Hmm. Andy discovers that Charles is a soccer fan, and now everybody is trying to kiss up to Charles and get on his good side. It's the first time we've seen the man smile. Jim is even going to pretend that he used to play soccer. This does not go well. No. You know what I loved about the storyline, and it's something BJ talked about in the
困难，但在帕姆的鼓励下，他决定组建一支梦之队来启动他们的公司，他们还将与一位潜在投资者会面。情况正在好转。是的。与此同时，在办公室里，查尔斯负责。我知道。在斯克兰顿。嗯。安迪发现查尔斯是个足球迷，现在每个人都在试图讨好查尔斯，争取他的好感。这是我们第一次看到这个人微笑。吉姆甚至要假装他以前踢过足球。这进行得并不顺利。不。你知道我喜欢这个故事情节的什么吗？这是BJ在这一集的
DVD commentary for this episode. He said, normally, when you break a story, you have the A story, which is the main story, and then you have the B story, which is like the other side dish, if you will. He said that Idris's scenes were so great, and the dynamic that Charles Miner had with the rest of the office was so interesting for them. They really felt like his storyline as two A stories. It felt like that. Yeah. Yeah. This felt like a very well-balanced episode. Right. I thought that was interesting. In fact, number one, this episode starts a delightful arc where Michael is going to run his own paper company. And I found out that it was our writer Charlie Grandy who came
DVD评论中谈到的。他说，通常当你构思一个故事时，你会有一个A故事，也就是主线故事，然后你会有一个B故事，如果你愿意的话，就像配菜一样。他说伊德里斯的场景太棒了，查尔斯·迈纳与办公室其他人的互动对他们来说非常有趣。他们真的觉得他的故事情节就像两个A故事。感觉确实如此。是的。是的。这感觉像是一集非常平衡的剧集。对。我觉得这很有趣。事实上，第一，这一集开启了一个令人愉快的篇章，迈克尔将经营自己的造纸公司。我发现是我们的编剧查理·格兰迪想出了
up with this idea, and they had been planning this arc for months. Oh. Well, he was on the DVD commentary for this episode. I don't know if they mentioned this on the commentary, but this episode was nominated for an Emmy for Outstanding Single Camera Editing for a Comedy Series. Our editors were nominated. That's fantastic. It was edited by Claire Scanlon. Now, Claire came in to replace Dean Holland when he moved over to work as an editor and eventually a director on Parks and Recreation. So now our two editors were Dave Rogers and Claire Scanlon. You might remember Claire because she had a cameo as Freckles in Lecture Circuit Part 2. Before this, she edited Golden Ticket, but Dream Team was her second episode
这个主意，他们已经为这个篇章策划了几个月。哦。好吧，他在这一集的DVD评论中。我不知道他们在评论中是否提到了这一点，但这一集获得了艾美奖喜剧类剧集最佳单机位剪辑提名。我们的剪辑师获得了提名。太棒了。它是由克莱尔·斯坎伦剪辑的。现在，克莱尔接替了迪恩·霍兰德，后者转去《公园与游憩》担任剪辑师，最终成为导演。所以现在我们的两位剪辑师是戴夫·罗杰斯和克莱尔·斯坎伦。你可能记得克莱尔，因为她在《讲座巡回第二部分》中客串了雀斑。在此之前，她剪辑了《金奖券》，但《梦之队》是她的第二集
and she was nominated for an Emmy. Claire. Claire. Of course, now Claire is like big badass director. Amazing. I would love to have Claire on. We should have Claire on. I know. Fast fact number two is a location breakdown. I knew you'd have one. Well, a good deal of this episode takes place at Michael's condo and this was not an easy feat. Randy Cordray told me we went back to the same condo complex where we shot Michael's condo before for dinner party and pretty much any episode featuring Michael's condo. It was in Recita, California and it was owned now by a married couple. In order to use their condo, we had to move them into a hotel for
她就获得了艾美奖提名。克莱尔。克莱尔。当然，现在克莱尔是一位了不起的硬核导演。太棒了。我很想请克莱尔来。我们应该请克莱尔来。我知道。速记事实之二是一个外景解析。我就知道你会有的。嗯，这一集很大一部分发生在迈克尔的公寓里，这可不是一件容易的事。兰迪·科德雷告诉我，我们回到了之前拍摄迈克尔公寓的同一个公寓大楼，用于《晚宴派对》以及几乎所有以迈克尔公寓为特色的剧集。它位于加利福尼亚州的雷西达，现在由一对已婚夫妇拥有。为了使用他们的公寓，我们不得不把他们搬到酒店住
an entire week. Okay. We had to take all of their stuff out. They put it into cartons in the garage. We painted the entire downstairs and decorated it. They made a point to decorate it differently from dinner party because, you know, now Michael is single. Yes. I noticed the only thing that remained that I recognized from dinner party was the St. Pauli girl beer sign. Same in the dining room. Yes. We only shot at this condo for one day and then they had to completely restore it back to the way the couple had it. Here is the thing that is fascinating to me because what they would do is they would take like a gazillion photos of every shelf, of everything. Anything that we moved, they took a picture
整整一周。好吧。我们不得不把他们所有的东西都搬走。他们把东西装进车库的纸箱里。我们把整个楼下都粉刷了一遍并进行了装饰。他们特意装饰得与《晚宴派对》不同，因为，你知道，现在迈克尔单身了。是的。我注意到我从《晚宴派对》中认出的唯一剩下的东西是圣保利女孩啤酒招牌。餐厅里也是一样的。是的。我们只在这个公寓拍摄了一天，然后他们必须完全把它恢复成那对夫妇原来的样子。这就是让我着迷的地方，因为他们会做的是，他们会拍无数张照片，每一层架子，每一件东西。任何我们移动的东西，他们在移动之前都拍了照片
of it before they moved it and they would put it in a binder, like hard copy photos because back then, you know, that's what it was. Yes. It would be like kitchen counter. Yes. Know that when the people came back, like even their little spoon caddy was where they left it or if they had a bookshelf, all their stuff, the books were in the same order as before. The picture frames were right where they left them. Everything. Everything. Isn't that fascinating? I know. It is amazing. In the DVD commentary, BJ talked about how carefully they decorated every wall. They put so much thought in detail and you just see it just quickly in the background, but I caught a few things I'm sure you guys did too. I'm
，然后他们会把它们放在一个活页夹里，就像纸质照片一样，因为那时候，你知道，就是那样。是的。就像厨房台面。是的。要知道当人们回来时，甚至他们的小勺子架都在他们离开的地方，或者如果他们有书架，他们所有的东西，书的顺序都和以前一样。相框就在他们离开的地方。一切。一切。这不迷人吗？我知道。这太神奇了。在DVD评论中，BJ谈到了他们装饰每一面墙是多么小心。他们投入了如此多的心思和细节，你只是在背景中快速看到它，但我捕捉到了一些东西，我相信你们也捕捉到了。我
going to bring them up when we get to it. I love it. Fast fact number three is a guest star homage to the amazing actress who played Nana. Her name is Connie Sawyer. Just incredible. We got a piece of mail from Meredith Q who wrote, I did a deep dive. The woman who played Nana needs some recognition. Yes, she does. First of all, she lived to be 105. Who does that? Wow. Is what Meredith said. And according to IMDB, her first acting credit was in 1953 at the age of 40. Her last acting credit was in 2014 at the age of 101. That 61 years of acting plus she acted over the age of 100. What a rock star. Tell me everything. Well, I looked into this woman and performance had
会在我们讲到那里时提出来。我喜欢。速记事实之三是对扮演娜娜的了不起的女演员的客串致敬。她的名字叫康妮·索耶。简直不可思议。我们收到了一封来自梅雷迪思·Q的邮件，她写道，我做了一次深入研究。扮演娜娜的那位女士需要得到认可。是的，她确实需要。首先，她活到了105岁。谁能做到这一点？哇。这就是梅雷迪思说的。根据IMDB，她的第一个表演作品是在1953年，当时她40岁。她最后一个表演作品是在2014年，当时她101岁。那是61年的演艺生涯，而且她在100岁之后还在演戏。真是个摇滚明星。告诉我一切。嗯，我研究了这个女人，表演已经
been a part of her life, her whole life. She had done vaudeville. She had performed live with Frank Sinatra, but it's true that she never had a film or television role until she was 40. So on the commentary, the writers were talking about her on set. They said she had the most amazing stories. She was throwing out stories about Bing Crosby, Bob Hope. They were just like, oh my gosh, she was fascinating. What I love about her story, Jenna, is that she did stage shows for years. She didn't get an on camera role till 40, but this was her passion. And you should never let anyone take that away from you. However, your passion manifests itself. I just love her story. She just kept at it. She has over 140 acting credits
成为她生活的一部分，她的一生。她演过杂耍剧。她曾与弗兰克·辛纳屈同台演出，但确实直到40岁她才获得电影或电视角色。所以在评论中，编剧们在片场谈论她。他们说她有最神奇的故事。她随口说出关于宾·克罗斯比、鲍勃·霍普的故事。他们简直就像，哦天哪，她太迷人了。珍娜，我喜欢她的故事的一点是，她演了多年的舞台剧。她直到40岁才获得出镜角色，但这却是她的热情所在。你永远不应该让任何人夺走这一点。无论你的热情如何体现。我只是喜欢她的故事。她一直坚持下去。她有超过140个表演作品
and almost all of them are small roles. And she has this quote about her acting career where she said, life is fun. That has nothing to do with whether you become a star or not. And if the parts aren't too large, I can go around talking to everybody. It's like going to a party. And when she was 104, she wrote an autobiography called, I never wanted to be a star and I wasn't. And she self published it in 2017 at 104. Wow. Well, that is amazing. BJ said the scenes that you guys did with her, that when they threw out some improv, she didn't miss a beat. Well, I remember her from when Harry met Sally. She is one of the women in the couples that they interview documentary style. Yes. Yes. She has no lines. Her husband
而且几乎都是小角色。她对自己的演艺生涯有一句名言，她说，生活很有趣。这与你是否成为明星无关。如果角色不是太大，我可以到处和每个人聊天。就像去参加派对一样。当她104岁时，她写了一本自传，叫《我从不想成为明星，我也没成为》。她在2017年104岁时自费出版了它。哇。嗯，那太神奇了。BJ说你们和她演的那些场景，当他们即兴发挥时，她一点也没掉链子。嗯，我记得她在《当哈利遇到莎莉》里的表演。她是他们以纪录片风格采访的夫妇中的女性之一。是的。是的。她没有台词。她的丈夫
speaks the whole time, but it all plays out on her face. And she is so good. And she has this story where she says that she read the script and she went to Rob Reiner and she said, I want to be the woman in the deli who says the famous line, I'll have what she's loving. She said, I want the show stopping line. And he said, I'm sorry, we already shot that. My mother did it. Yeah, his mom did it. But she's just so good. She passed away in 2018 at the age of 105. And at the time of her death, she was the oldest working actress in Hollywood and the oldest member of the Screen Actors Guild Union. Amazing woman. Amazing. Connie Sawyer, everybody. Well, that's all I've got for Fast Facts.
一直在说话，但一切都表现在她的脸上。她太棒了。她有一个故事，说她读了剧本，然后去找罗伯·莱纳，她说，我想成为熟食店里说那句名言的女人，我会要她点的东西。她说，我想要那句抢戏的台词。他说，对不起，我们已经拍完了。我妈妈演的。是的，他妈妈演的。但她就是那么好。她于2018年去世，享年105岁。在她去世时，她是好莱坞最年长的在职女演员，也是演员工会最年长的成员。了不起的女人。了不起。康妮·索耶，大家。好吧，这就是我所有的速记事实。
But before we go to break, you know, Marcus York, who played Billy Merchant. Yeah. Is in this episode. This is his last appearance on the show. And he actually passed away earlier this year. He was just wonderful. And he was so wonderful to us. He shared a story with us. He did. He and I would text and we talked on the phone several times. He loved his character of Billy Merchant. He was so supportive of the show. And we were just so fond of him. We got a letter from a man named Nathan N. And I thought this summed up Marcus pretty well. He said, I just wanted to comment on Marcus York, because I believe this is his last episode. And I wanted to let people know what kind of guy he is. He was from Dark County,
但在我们休息之前，你知道，扮演比利·莫昌特的马库斯·约克。是的。在这一集中。这是他在剧中的最后一次露面。他实际上在今年早些时候去世了。他真是太棒了。他对我们太好了。他与我们分享了一个故事。他确实分享了。我和他会发短信，我们还通过几次电话。他热爱比利·莫昌特这个角色。他非常支持这部剧。我们非常喜欢他。我们收到了一封来自内森·N的男士的信。我觉得这很好地总结了马库斯。他说，我只是想评论一下马库斯·约克，因为我相信这是他的最后一集。我想让人们知道他是个什么样的人。他来自达克县，
Ohio, which is near where I work as a police officer. Just so happens that my partner met him one night when he was checking on him when he pulled over to use his phone. Upon Marcus telling him he was on the office, my partner said that he's never watched the show, but that I did and I was going to be so bummed that I missed him because I've talked about him in the past. Marcus asked him if I was working and he said I wouldn't be in for about an hour. Not only did Marcus wait that hour, but on top of that, he took a picture with me, his idea, hung out for an hour and gave me an autographed picture made out to my wife. He seemed so happy to meet a fan that knew him and was interested in him and
俄亥俄州，离我作为警察工作的地方很近。碰巧我的搭档有一天晚上在检查他时遇到了他，当时他靠边停车用手机。在马库斯告诉他他出演了《办公室》后，我的搭档说他从来没看过这部剧，但我看过，如果我错过了他，我会非常沮丧，因为我过去常谈论他。马库斯问他我是否在上班，他说我大约一个小时后才会来。马库斯不仅等了那一个小时，最重要的是，他还和我拍了张照片，这是他的主意，待了一个小时，并给了我一张写给我妻子的亲笔签名照片。他似乎很高兴见到一个认识他并对他感兴趣的粉丝，
his career. Even though I only met him that one time, he definitely left a lasting impression for sure. Such a nice guy and a tragic loss. That is so well said. He was such a nice person. And he was so aware of the joy that he could bring to people by just being open to that fan experience or talking about his time on the show. And he certainly did that with us here at Office Ladies. He did. Much love to Marcus and his family. All right, let's go to break. Let's do it. Well, we are back from break. And before we get into Dream Team, I couldn't help but remember the OG Dream Team, Jenna. Was it basketball? Yes. Yes. You guys, the 1992 United
以及他的职业生涯。尽管我只见过他那一次，但他确实留下了深刻的印象。真是个好人，也是一个悲剧性的损失。说得太好了。他真是个好人。他非常清楚，仅仅通过对粉丝体验保持开放态度或谈论他在剧中的时光，他就能给人们带来快乐。他确实在《办公室》女士这里做到了这一点。他确实做到了。向马库斯和他的家人致以深切的爱。好了，让我们休息一下。开始吧。嗯，我们休息回来了。在进入《梦之队》之前，我忍不住想起了最初的梦之队，珍娜。是篮球吗？是的。是的。伙计们，1992年美国
States men's Olympic basketball team, nicknamed the Dream Team. It was the first American Olympic team to feature active professional players from the National Basketball Association. And the team has been described from journalists around the world as the greatest sports team ever assembled. Wow. I know. I mean, I totally remember that. Me too. It was a big deal. It was a big deal, you guys. And listen, this is like when I was in school. So when this episode was coming up, whenever I saw the title Dream Team, I just always think, that's what I think of too. Yeah, I don't know if you guys think of that. But I just want to read the roster and just a few stats, okay, of this team. All right, the full roster for
男子奥运篮球队，绰号梦之队。这是第一支拥有来自美国国家篮球协会的现役职业球员的美国奥运代表队。这支球队被世界各地的记者描述为有史以来组建的最伟大的运动队。哇。我知道。我的意思是，我完全记得那个。我也是。那是一件大事。那是一件大事，伙计们。听着，这就像我在上学的时候。所以当这一集要播出时，每当我看到《梦之队》这个标题，我总是会想到，这也是我想到的。是的，我不知道你们是否也这么想。但我只是想读一下名单和一些统计数据，好吗，关于这支球队。好的，1992年梦之队的完整名单是
the 1992 Dream Team was Charles Barkley, Larry Bird, Patrick Ewing, Magic Johnson, Michael Jordan, Carl Malone, Chris Mullins, Scottie Pippin, David Robinson, John Stockton. Then they added two players later, Clyde Drexler, and they included one collegiate player, Christian Leightner of Duke University, who was chosen over Louisiana State University's Shaquille O'Neal. Wow. Yeah. Head coach was Chuck Daly. Here are some things I thought were fun. The co-captains of the team were Larry Bird and Magic Johnson. They were undefeated in the Olympics. Chuck Daly used zero timeouts for the entire eight games. Not a single timeout was called, which is wild to me. Larry Bird was the oldest member of the Dream Team, and
查尔斯·巴克利、拉里·伯德、帕特里克·尤因、魔术师约翰逊、迈克尔·乔丹、卡尔·马龙、克里斯·穆林、斯科蒂·皮蓬、大卫·罗宾逊、约翰·斯托克顿。后来他们又增加了两名球员，克莱德·德雷克斯勒，他们还包括了一名大学生球员，杜克大学的克里斯蒂安·莱特纳，他被选中而不是路易斯安那州立大学的沙奎尔·奥尼尔。哇。是的。主教练是查克·戴利。这里有一些我觉得很有趣的事情。球队的联合队长是拉里·伯德和魔术师约翰逊。他们在奥运会上保持不败。查克·戴利在整整八场比赛中没有叫过一次暂停。一次暂停都没有叫，这对我来说太疯狂了。拉里·伯德是梦之队中最年长的成员，
guess how old he was? He was the oldest member of the Dream Team. 41. 35. Wow. That was the old guy. And I thought this was interesting. Guess who led the Dream Team in scoring? I'm going to admit here that I don't watch basketball, and I don't know anything about basketball. So I know these people's names, and I know that they played basketball. Okay. Okay. Well, I would have guessed Michael Jordan. Who shoots the most? Wouldn't you have guessed Michael Jordan, Sam, Cassie? He's a good player. He's amazing. Watch the last dance documentary. Amazing. I would have guessed Michael Jordan, but in fact, it was Charles Barkley, and Michael Jordan came in second. Oh, how about them apples? But anyway, when I think of Dream Team,
猜猜他多大？他是梦之队中最年长的成员。41岁。35岁。哇。那是老家伙。我觉得这很有趣。猜猜谁是梦之队的得分王？我在这里承认，我不看篮球，我对篮球一无所知。所以我知道这些人的名字，我知道他们打篮球。好的。好的。嗯，我会猜迈克尔·乔丹。谁投篮最多？你难道不会猜迈克尔·乔丹吗，萨姆，卡西？他是个好球员。他太棒了。看《最后之舞》纪录片。太棒了。我会猜迈克尔·乔丹，但事实上，是查尔斯·巴克利，迈克尔·乔丹排在第二。哦，那又怎么样呢？但无论如何，当我想到梦之队时，
I think of the OG Dream Team. But you know, Jenna, this isn't the only time in the course of our show that we mention the Dream Team. When else do we mention the Dream Team? Bonus points if you can guess this. The Dream Team in Meredith. I mean, I'm assuming it's a party planning thing, but I don't know what episode that's from. The Dream Team in Meredith is from, some of you out there probably guessed this, season seven, Goodbye, Michael. Oh, and it was about the party planning committee. It's Angela, Phyllis, and Pam. And then Meredith kind of pops her head in the back. Are we planning the goodbye party for Michael? Is that what's going to happen? I think so. All right. So Dream Team, two of them in the course
我想到的是最初的梦之队。但你知道吗，珍娜，这不是我们在节目过程中唯一一次提到梦之队。我们还在什么时候提到过梦之队？如果你能猜到这个，加分。梅雷迪思里的梦之队。我的意思是，我假设这是派对策划的事情，但我不知道那是哪一集。梅雷迪思里的梦之队来自，你们中的一些人可能猜到了，第七季，《再见，迈克尔》。哦，那是关于派对策划委员会的。是安吉拉、菲利斯和帕姆。然后梅雷迪思在后面探出头来。我们在策划迈克尔的告别派对吗？是会发生那种事吗？我想是的。好的。所以梦之队，在《办公室》过程中有两个。一个是迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司，也就是维克拉姆、帕姆、瑞安和迈克尔，另一个是派对策划委员会。好吧，让我们进入这一集，珍娜，因为电话在响。凯文在接待处。情况不太好。他非常努力地转接这些电话。我的意思是，他只是在办公室里大喊大叫，而不是转接电话，因为他不记得每个人的分机。他还在大喊一些私人的事情，比如奥斯卡的妈妈打来电话，这让我笑死了。是的。他在办公区大喊。好吧，他要尝试把电话转给安迪。是的。但首先他要把它转给办公室里几乎所有的其他办公桌。他要跑来跑去
of the office. One is Michael Scott Paper Company, which is Vikram, Pam, Ryan, and Michael, and the other is the party planning committee. Well, let's get into this episode, Jenna, because phones are ringing. Kevin's at reception. It's not going well. He's trying so hard to transfer these calls. I mean, he's just yelling across the office rather than transfer the calls because he can't remember everyone's extension. And he's sort of yelling personal stuff like it cracked me up that Oscar's mom was calling. Yes. He yelled it across the bullpen. Well, he is going to try to transfer a call to Andy. Yeah. But first he's going to transfer it to pretty much every other desk in the office. He's going to run around
然后转接，然后转接，然后转接。是的，就像它转到了克里德那里，然后它转到了，他只是到处乱跑。我们收到了来自墨西哥的布伦达·R的问题，她想知道，布莱恩在片场是真的在转接电话，还是这只是一些幕后魔法？嗯，当我在接待处扮演帕姆时，他们有一份真实分机的列表，因为电话是真的能用。是的。我真的会转接电话。但最初的铃声会来自幕后的某个人。有一张桌子，上面有一部电话，也连接到我们后台的电话。所以当你想要转接电话时有两个选择。要么你真的做了
and then transfer it and then transfer it and transfer it. Yeah, like it goes to Creed and then it goes, he's just running all over the place. We got a question from Brenda R. in Mexico who wants to know, was Brian really transferring the phone calls on set or was this some behind the scenes magic? Well, when I would be Pam at the reception desk, they had a list of the real extensions because the phones really worked. Yeah. And I would really transfer the calls. But the initial ring would come from somebody behind the scenes. There was a desk with a phone that was also connected to our phones backstage. So there were two options when you wanted to transfer a call. Either you did it for real
，要么你只是挂断，后台的人会让另一个人的电话响。但这需要他们试图对着对讲机耳语来协调这一切。是的。所以我总是直接转接电话。我的意思是，我有我现实生活中的接待员经验。是的。我得把它用上。是的。但我不知道布莱恩做了什么。所以我给他发了短信，他说他也真的转接了电话。但他必须记住分机，因为他跑来跑去。第一次转接后，他不能再带着他的纸条了。对。哦，天哪。我仍然有一张贴在我电话上的所有转接号码的照片。我拍了张照片
or you would just hang up and the person backstage would make another person's phone ring. But that would require them sort of trying to whisper into a walkie talkie to get them to coordinate all that. Yeah. So I always just transferred the calls. I mean, I had my real life receptionist experience. Yeah. I got to put it to use. Yeah. But I didn't know what Brian did. So I texted him and he said he also really transferred the calls. But he would have to remember the extensions because he was running around. After the first transfer, he couldn't take his slip of paper with him anymore. Right. Oh my gosh. I still have a photo of all of our transfer numbers that was taped to my phone. I took a picture
。哦，哇。是的。嗯，在DVD评论中，我们的摄像师马特·索恩与我们分享说，在他们拍摄的那天，布莱恩在进行转接，但电话出了一些问题。所以它们没有转到它们应该去的办公桌群。所以布莱恩实际上最终跑到了铃声响起的任何地方。哦，哇。所以那种狂躁有点真实。他真的不知道它会在哪里响。我想至少有一次它没有在应该响的地方响。而他只是跑了。马特说他们只是跟着他。我们有一个来自斯克兰顿的莫妮卡的问题，安吉拉。这个是给你的。好的。当安吉拉大喊，
of it. Oh, wow. Yeah. Well, in the DVD commentary, Matt Sohn, our camera operator, shared with us that on the day they were filming, Brian was doing the transferring, but they were having some issues with the phones. And so they weren't going to some of the desk clumps they were supposed to. And so Brian actually ended up running around to wherever it was ringing. Oh, wow. So that mania was a little real. He really didn't know where it was going to ring. I think there's at least one time where it didn't ring where it was supposed to. And he just ran. And Matt said they were just following him. We had a fan question from Monica in Scranton, Angela. And this one's for you. Okay. When Angela yells out,
你在这方面也很差。你是暗示帕姆在这方面很差吗？凯文也是，还是说凯文什么都做不好？嗯，首先，那句台词是有剧本的。那不是即兴发挥。而且我认为安吉拉只是暗示凯文什么都做得很糟糕。好的。我其实不认为这是针对帕姆的挖苦。我认为这更多是对凯文的挖苦。我们还收到了一封来自格蕾丝·B的邮件。她说，凯文教我如何转接电话。她说她是高中的办公室助理。他们换了新的电话系统。她不知道该怎么办，但她记得这一集，转接分机转接，它成功了。哦，天哪。所以她说，谢谢。不客气。嗯，在剧本里，
you're bad at this too. Were you implying that Pam is bad at it? And so is Kevin or that Kevin is bad at everything? Well, first of all, that line is scripted. That was not improv. And I think Angela is just implying that Kevin is horrible at everything. Okay. I actually don't think it's a dig at Pam for once. I think it's more of a dig at Kevin. We also got a piece of mail from Grace B. Who said, Kevin taught me how to transfer a call. She said she was an office aide in high school. They got a new phone system. She wasn't sure what to do, but she remembered this episode, transfer extension transfer, and it worked. Oh my gosh. So she says, thank you. You're welcome. Well, in the script,
当凯文终于把电话转给安迪时，这是舞台指导。人们即兴发挥，干得好。好的。鼓掌。给凯文碰拳。他非常高兴。在安迪的采访背景中，庆祝活动还在继续。凯文摇晃一罐苏打水并打开它。那非常像梦之队。我知道。非常体育式的庆祝。我知道。嗯，现在帕姆要开始她的第一天工作了。第一天。有一个标志，什么都有。我知道。这是正式的。我不知道你是否注意到了她的小西装外套。我注意到了。关于我们从哪里开始这个篇章，有一个非常大的服装讨论。是的。帕姆的“我是纸张推销员”的装束是什么。是的。所以这里有一件事。我们最初想，她应该
when Kevin finally gets the call to Andy, this was the stage direction. People add lib, way to go. All right. Applaud. Giving Kevin fist bumps. He is very happy. In the background of Andy's talking head, the celebration continues. Kevin shakes up a soda can and opens it. That's very dream team ask. I know. Very sports celebration. I know. Well, now Pam is going to arrive for her first day of work. First day. There's a sign and everything. I know. It's official. I don't know if you noticed her little blazer. I did. There was a very big wardrobe discussion about where we started this arc. Yes. For what Pams, I'm a paper salesman outfit is. Yes. So here's one thing. We originally thought, should she
穿裤装吗，就像那种权力套装。太大胆了，帕姆。但听听这个。在早些时候的一季中，曾经讨论过帕姆是否可以有时穿裤子去办公室，因为她总是穿开衫和铅笔裙，什么都一样。这一直传到了电视网。电视网说，帕姆必须穿铅笔裙。是的。好的。我一直对这个感到好奇，珍娜。我从来没告诉过你，但有几集，他们让安吉拉·马丁穿了西裤，然后突然裤子就不见了。所以我去了服装部，我说，嘿，我们能带回西裤吗？那些太舒服了。他们说，哦，其实，我们收到通知说他们只想让你穿裙子。
wear a pants suit, like kind of a power suit. So bold, Pam. But listen to this. In an earlier season, there had been a discussion about if Pam could sometimes wear pants to the office because she had such a uniform of her cardigan and her pencil skirt and everything. And it went all the way up to the network. And the network said, Pam must wear pencil skirts. Yeah. Okay. I have wondered about this, Jenna. And I've never told you this, but for a few episodes, they put Angela Martin in dress pants and then all of a sudden the pants went away. And so I went to wardrobe and I said, Hey, can we bring back the dress pants? Those are so comfortable. And they said, Oh, actually, we got a note that they just want you in skirts.
这不有趣吗？我不知道你也收到了同样的通知。我觉得这太疯狂了。所以我们被提醒我不能穿裤装。我们必须保留铅笔裙。所以我们唯一能改变的就是我上半身的衣服。NBC高层里是谁说办公室女士必须穿裙子的？嗯，看看菲利斯总是穿裙子。梅雷迪思总是穿某种背带裙。凯利。凯利。简。还有内莉。裙子。然而，凯伦总是穿裤子。我不认为她穿过裙子。而且我认为有时霍莉穿裤子。我说得对吗？但主要是连衣裙和裙子。乔·贝内特穿裤子。但那些都是客串明星。核心演员必须穿裙子，我想。我
Isn't that interesting? I did not know you got the same note. I thought that was crazy. And so we were reminded that I could not wear a pants suit. We had to keep the pencil skirt. So only thing we could change was the top half of my body. Who was the brass at the top of NBC that was like office ladies must wear skirts. Well, look at Phyllis always in a skirt. Meredith always in some kind of jumper. Kelly. Kelly. Jan. And Nellie. Skirts. However, Karen always wore pants. I don't think she ever wore a skirt. And I think that sometimes Holly wore pants. Am I right? But mostly it was dresses and skirts. Joe Bennett wore pants. But those were all guest stars. Core cast had to be in skirts, I guess. I
不知道。当时电视网的高层是谁？是《广告狂人》里的那个人吗？是唐·德雷珀在经营电视网吗？那是我可能要发表长篇大论的人吗？不，我要把它留着。我会留着。让我们留着吧。每个人都知道。他们听到了。他们听到它是微妙的。它就在那里。好的，所以底线是这就是我们所做的。我把连裤袜换成了紧身裤。我穿了一点点高跟鞋，一点权力鞋和西装外套。所以它们是小的改变，但它们确实感觉很有影响力。我觉得帕姆感觉更精致了。是的。那是我们的目标。嗯，迈克尔要穿着浴袍开始他的第一天工作。帕姆说，迈克尔，你在等我，对吧？
don't know. Who was the network brass at the time? Was it the guy from Mad Men? Was Don Draper running the network? Is that who maybe I fill a soap box of coming? No, I'm gonna leave it. I'll leave it. Let's leave it. Everyone knows it. They heard it. They heard it was subtle. It was there. Okay, so bottom line is here's what we did. I switched out my pantyhose for tights. I'm wearing a little bit more of a heel bit of a power shoe and a blazer. So they were little changes, but they did feel impactful. I thought Pam felt a little more polished. Yeah. That was our goal. Well, Michael is going to start his first day of work in a bathrobe. Pam's like, Michael, you were expecting me, weren't you?
他说，是的。是的。她说，你袍子下面穿了什么吗？他说，那不合适。他把她带进去，他实际上已经布置好了他的餐厅。有点像办公室。很好。确实很好。我想这些都是他离开时从供应柜里拿走的东西。显然。他开始做法国吐司。很多法国吐司。有一个被删减的帕姆采访，她解释了她加入迈克尔的动机。当他在做法国吐司时，她走到露台上。在这里。我感觉准备好迎接改变了。在邓德·米夫林这么多年后，我只是没有从接待员工作中得到我过去得到的那种冲动。这感觉很好。
He's like, yeah. Yeah. She's like, are you wearing anything under the robe? And he's like, that's inappropriate. He brings her inside and he actually has set up his dining room. Sort of office-like. It's nice. It is nice. I think these are all items he took from the supply chest as he was leaving. Clearly. And he starts making French toast. A lot of French toast. And there was a deleted Pam talking head where she explains her motivation to join Michael. She steps outside on the patio while he's making French toast. Here it is. I felt ready for a change. After all these years at Dunder Mifflin, I just wasn't getting the same rush that I used to get from being a receptionist. This feels good.
这个鸡蛋打不开。哦，好吧。鸡蛋打不开。是的。他打断她让她帮他打鸡蛋。帕姆享受她的法国吐司。它非常好。我吃了。你真的吃了？它很美味。那只是真实的。干得好，道具食物。我知道。我们有一个来自艾拉·H的粉丝问题，她说谁必须做所有的法国吐司？菲尔·谢和他的团队。他们做了很多法国吐司。但问题是，迈克尔停不下来做法国吐司。帕姆意识到这是因为他在真正开始这家新公司时有一些感受。她试图让他停止搅拌鸡蛋，结果鸡蛋洒了他一身。洒了他一身，还洒进了他的洞洞鞋里。我们收到了关于
This egg won't crack. Oh, okay. The egg won't crack. Yeah. He interrupts her to help him crack eggs. Pam enjoys her French toast. It was very good. I ate it. Did you really? It was delicious. That was just real. Way to go, prop food. I know. We had a fan question from Ayla H who said who had to make all the French toast? Phil Shea and his team. They made a bunch of French toast. But here's the problem. Michael won't stop making French toast. And Pam realizes it's because he's having some feelings about really getting started in this new company. She tries to get him to stop mixing the eggs and it ends up spilling eggs all over him. All over him and into his crocs. We got questions about
那个的问题。人们想知道，碗里是真鸡蛋吗？“我洞洞鞋里有鸡蛋”这句台词是即兴发挥的吗？人们也很好奇，我们是怎么做这个场景的？因为每次让鸡蛋掉在同一个地方似乎很难。嗯，我会说史蒂夫确实即兴发挥了“我洞洞鞋里有鸡蛋”这句台词。很难不笑，但这是真的。我们无法让鸡蛋每次都以同样的方式溅出来。所以我不能笑，因为这是一个赢家。我们必须使用整个镜头。我们不能在不同的镜头之间剪辑，因为鸡蛋会不同。压力太大了。和史蒂夫在一起很难不笑。我知道。但我没有。但我认为你可以看出我有多努力不笑
that. People wanted to know, was it real egg in the bowl? Was the line, I have egg in my crocs improvised? And people are also curious, how did we do this scene? Because it seems difficult to have the egg go in the same place each time. Well, I will say that Steve did improvise the line, I have egg in my crocs. It was very hard not to laugh, but it's true. We couldn't get the egg to splash in the same way every time. So I could not laugh because this was a winner. We would have to use a whole take. We couldn't cut between different takes because the egg would be different. So much pressure. It's so hard to not laugh with Steve. I know. But I didn't. But I think you can tell how hard I am trying not to laugh
在这个场景里。你便秘了吗还是什么？是的，我确实。我看起来就像你可以看出我像是在紧张地忍着。但这奏效了。它看起来就像帕姆在看着一个她认为应该知道自己在做什么的人，而他显然不知道。她就像，哦，该死，我把自己卷进了什么事里？嗯，我们确实拍了几次这个场景，每次都是一个大的重置，因为我们必须清理厨房里所有的鸡蛋。我们必须清理史蒂夫身上所有的鸡蛋。他必须换掉他的浴袍。但这一条是完美的。这是他即兴发挥那句台词的时候，鸡蛋到处都是。所以我站在那里也知道，这就是那一条。不要搞砸了。对。所以
in this scene. Do you constipate it or something? Yeah, I do. I look like you can tell I'm like tensely holding in. It works though. It just looks like Pam is like watching someone who she thinks is supposed to know what they're doing, who clearly doesn't. She's like, oh, crap, what have I gotten myself into? Well, we did do several takes of this and it was a big reset every time because we would have to clean up all the eggs in the kitchen. We'd have to clean up all the eggs on Steve. He would have to change his bathrobe. But this one was perfect. This was the time he improvised that line and the egg just went everywhere. So I also knew as I was standing there, this is the one. Do not mess this up. Right. So
有一点要指出，伙计们，我喜欢我们节目的这一点，让我为你们书呆子一下。既然史蒂夫即兴发挥了“洞洞鞋里有鸡蛋”这句台词，这意味着我们的摄像师必须即兴发挥动作来向下摇镜头到他的脚。是的。那不是计划好的，但它卖出了这个笑话。太棒了。真是个伟大的双人戏。我们在这个厨房场景中也有一个粉丝捕捉。塞拉·G和劳伦·W指出，在4分31秒，他厨房台面上有一个标志写着“他的”。是的。但没有“她的”。她的。我也看到了。他们就像，我猜简离开时带走了她的。或者也许她从来没想过把她的拿出来。也许迈克尔只是买了一个“他的”。我想他买了一个“他的”
one thing to point out, you guys, which I love about our show, to nerd out on you for a minute. Since Steve improvised the line, eggs in my crocs, that meant our camera operator had to improvise the move to pan down to his feet. Yes. That wouldn't have been planned, but it sells the joke. So good. Such a great two-hander. We also had a fan catch in this scene in the kitchen. Sierra G and Lauren W point out that at four minutes 31 seconds, there's a sign on his kitchen counter that says his. Yeah. But there is no hers. Hers. I saw that too. And they were like, I guess Jan took the hers when she left. Or maybe she never even wanted hers out. Maybe Michael just bought a his. I think he bought a his
“她的”，而她从来没拿出来。我不知道。无论结果如何，这都很悲伤。我们应该回到办公室看看那里发生了什么吗？是的，因为这是一个非常有趣的会议室场景。我们和伊德里斯玩得很开心。他像迈克尔过去那样主持会议，他告诉他们既然他们失去了两名员工，事情将如何进行。但凯利和安吉拉只想知道更多关于查尔斯的事。我喜欢凯利说，你住在斯克兰顿哪里？他说酒店。安吉拉说，你出生在哪里？你出生在哪里？太有趣了。很难不笑。我想让你们知道，当安迪问公司运营情况如何时
her and she never put hers out. I don't know. It's sad no matter how it shook out. Should we go back to the office and see what's happening back there? Yes, because this was a really fun conference room scene. We were having a absolute blast with Idris. He's holding court the way Michael used to, and he's telling them how things are going to proceed now that they've lost two employees. But Kelly and Angela just want to know more about Charles. I love that Kelly's like, where are you staying in Scranton? And he's like a hotel. And Angela goes, where were you born? Where were you born? It was so fun. It was hard not to laugh. And I want you guys to know when Andy asked how the operations of the company are going
在背景中，我捕捉到了布莱恩脱离角色。他在这一刻显然只是布莱恩。如果你去3分2秒，它非常微妙，但看看他的脸。那是布莱恩，不是凯文。我要给你看一张照片，珍娜，因为我们在这一幕里玩得很开心。有所有这些时刻，你不知道你是否在镜头前，有时看看那张脸。哦，那是布莱恩。我知道。那是100%的布莱恩。他只是试图不笑，他在看着约翰。嗯，然后我们将看到菲利斯、克里德和斯坦利在观察查尔斯在他的办公室里。查尔斯在打电话。他们就像，他吃东西吗？他去洗手间吗？
in the background, I caught Brian out of character. He is clearly just Brian in this moment. If you go to three minutes, two seconds, it's very subtle, but look at his face. That is Brian and not Kevin. I'm going to show you a picture, Jenna, because we were just having a great time in this scene. There were all these moments when you didn't know if you were on camera and sometimes look at that face. Oh, that's Brian. I know. That's 100% Brian. He's just trying not to laugh and he's looking at John. Well then we're going to see Phyllis Creed and Stanley sort of observing Charles in his office. Charles is on the phone. They're like, does he eat? Does he go to the bathroom?
他是他们眼中的一个谜。珍娜，这还有更多。有一系列采访，办公室里的每个人都在评论查尔斯是一个谜。从安吉拉·马丁开始。准备好迎接一些兴奋的安吉拉。查尔斯是一个谜。我希望有一种方法可以让我蜷缩在他身边的火堆旁，直接翻到他的最后一页。好的。我爱死那个短语了。下次我诱惑我丈夫时，我要说，宝贝，我想直接翻到你的最后一页。我知道，对吧？看看他怎么说。我喜欢那个。我觉得那太棒了。然后托比有一个，托比基本上就像，我不知道为什么每个人都认为查尔斯是一个谜。如果有人愿意回来
He's the total mystery to them. Jenna, there was more to this. There was a series of talking heads where everyone in the office is sort of commenting on how Charles is a mystery. It starts with Angela Martin. Get ready for some titillated Angela. Charles is a mystery. I wish there was a way I could curl up by the fire with him and flip right to his last page. Okay. I am in love with that phrase. The next time I seduce my husband, I'm going to say, baby, I want to flip right to your last page. I know, right? See what he says. I love that. I thought that was amazing. And then Toby has one and Toby basically is like, I don't know why everyone thinks Charles is a mystery. If anyone would just come back
和我谈谈，我可以和你分享。我有很多关于他的信息。如果有人只是想和我谈谈。我的意思是，我相信托比确实知道他出生在哪里，我想。是的。然后珍娜，查尔斯有一个非常大的采访。他超级放松。剧本里是这么说的。查尔斯看起来很放松，放下戒备，以一种他永远不会对员工说话的方式随意地对镜头说话。哦，这是拍摄草稿里的内容。神秘。仅仅因为我在谈论我的个人生活时对我的员工表现出一些克制，并不意味着有什么大谜团。我在华盛顿特区的郊区长大，中产阶级家庭。我爸爸是注册会计师，去了马里兰大学，学习商业，
and talk to me, I can share with you. I have a lot of information about him. If anyone just wants to talk to me. I mean, I'm sure Toby does know where he was born, I guess. Yeah. And then Jenna Charles had a really big talking head. He's super relaxed. This is what it said in the script. Charles seems relaxed, his guard down, speaking casually to the camera in a way he never would to his employees. Oh, and this is what was in the shooting draft. Mysterious. Just because I show some restraint with my employees when it comes to talking about my personal life doesn't mean there's some big mystery. I grew up in a suburb of DC, middle class family. My dad was a CPA, went to University of Maryland, studied business,
订婚过一次，童年朋友，没成功。然后他给镜头看了一张照片。我会永远爱她。然后我每个月的第一天理发。所以我记得3月1日总是剪得更少。我喜欢酸的食物，但我讨厌葡萄柚。说不出为什么，就是不喜欢。我有一只叫墨菲的长尾小鹦鹉，正在教它说话。它重复我说的一切。如果我说的话是“嘎”，这是谁？哦，天哪。那些采访会填补故事的其余部分。我想知道那个采访是否在某个地方存在。我不知道。戴夫·罗杰斯。戴夫·罗杰斯做到了，因为那是无价的，但安吉拉和托比的在DVD的删减片段里。回到
engaged once, childhood friend, didn't work out. Then he shows a picture to the camera. I'll always love her. Then I get my haircut on the first day of every month. So I remember there's always less to cut on March 1st. I like sour foods, but I hate grapefruit. Couldn't tell you why just don't get it. I have a parakeet named Murphy trying to teach it to talk. It repeats whatever I say. If the thing I say is squawk, who is this person? Oh my gosh. Those talking heads would have filled out the rest of the story. I wonder if that talking head exists somewhere. I don't know. Dave Rogers. Dave Rogers does it because that is priceless, but the Angela and Toby one are in the deleted scenes on the DVD. Back at
迈克尔的公寓，他在做一些腹肌练习。他确实在做。珍娜，如果你在DVD评论里有一个摄像师，这里是你学到的一些事情。当迈克尔做仰卧起坐时，4分45秒帕姆身上的镜头，那是马特·索恩。哦，你是他的镜头。好的。我不知道。我只是喜欢那个。我们有一个来自吉安娜·W的粉丝问题。当迈克尔在他的公寓里锻炼时，那是他使用的来自《金钱》那一集的腹肌爆破器吗？记得吗，他把钱花在了腹肌爆破器上。我想是的。我去了剧本。它没有具体说明，但我被场景描述迷住了。在剧本里。哦，让我们听听。这是它说的。迈克尔正在他的腹肌上锻炼
Michael's condo, he is doing some ab exercises. He is. And Jenna, if you have a camera operator on a DVD commentary, here are some things you'd learn. While Michael's doing his sit-ups, the shot that's on Pam at four minutes, 45 seconds, that was Matt soon. Oh, you were his shot. Okay. I don't know. I just love that. We had a fan question from Gianna W. When Michael is working out in his condo, is that supposed to be the core blaster from the money episode that he's using? Remember, he spent his money on a core blaster. I think so. I went to the script. It doesn't say specifically, but I was so charmed by the scene description. In the script. Oh, let's hear it. Here's what it said. Michael is working out on his ab
迈克尔的公寓，他正在做一些腹肌练习。他确实在做。珍娜，如果你在DVD评论中有一位摄影师，你会学到一些东西。当迈克尔在做仰卧起坐时，四分四十五秒时拍帕姆的那个镜头，那是马特·苏恩拍的。哦，那是你拍的镜头。好吧。我不知道。我只是喜欢这一点。我们收到了来自吉安娜·W的粉丝提问。当迈克尔在他的公寓里锻炼时，他用的是《钱》那一集里的核心爆破器吗？记得吗，他把钱花在了核心爆破器上。我想是的。我查了剧本。上面没有具体说明，但我被剧本里的场景描述迷住了。哦，让我们听听看。上面是这样写的。迈克尔正在锻炼他的腹肌
roller incorrectly using no range of motion. That is what they wanted Steve to do. Pam can see that Michael is a little bit spiraling. Is that a good description? Yeah. And she says that when she feels overwhelmed, she likes to make a list of things to do and then start with the easy stuff. I think this is great life advice. We got mail about that advice. Oh, no. And I was really flattered because people say this reminds me of Jenna Fisher. Because I did too. When I rewatched this, I was like, it's a little bit of what is it again? Life imitating art. Yeah. I get it right. I got it right. I did. Shannon L said, Jenna, I know that I don't know you, but when Pam tells Michael he needs to make a list for his
滚轮使用不当，没有活动范围。这就是他们想让史蒂夫做的事。帕姆能看出迈克尔有点失控了。这个描述准确吗？是的。她说当她感到不知所措时，她喜欢列一张待办事项清单，然后从简单的事情做起。我觉得这是很棒的人生建议。我们收到了关于这个建议的邮件。哦，不。我真的很受宠若惊，因为人们说这让我想起了珍娜·费舍尔。因为我也这么做了。当我重温这一集时，我在想，这有点像什么来着？生活模仿艺术。是的。我理解对了。我做对了。我确实做到了。香农·L说，珍娜，我知道我不认识你，但当帕姆告诉迈克尔他需要为他的
day, that sounded like something you would do. And Kayla C agrees. She said, after listening to every episode of this podcast, I can say with confidence that is the most Jenna thing I've ever heard. I would have to say there are two things on the office that were 100% me. One is this list making advice. And the other is my line and dinner party when I say I just want to eat. Yeah. Those are me. You do have a tour list. You also have sort of like your meals planned for the week. I never wonder about that. I have a plan. I like to know what I'm eating and I like to check something off a list. You really do. I really do. When we went on our writer's retreat, I learned very quickly that you need to know what you're eating. Like that is no joke. I would be like,
一天列个清单时，那听起来像是你会做的事。凯拉·C也表示同意。她说，在听了这播客的每一集之后，我可以自信地说，这是我听过的最“珍娜”的事情了。我不得不说，《办公室》里有两件事是百分之百的我。一个是这个列清单的建议。另一个是我在“晚宴”那一集里的台词，我说我只是想吃东西。是的。那些就是我。你确实有一份待办清单。你还有那种为一周计划好的餐食。我从来没想过这个问题。我有一个计划。我喜欢知道我在吃什么，也喜欢在清单上勾掉一些东西。你确实如此。我真的有。当我们去参加作家静修会时，我很快就了解到你需要知道你在吃什么。那可不是开玩笑的。我会说，
what should we do for dinner? You'd be like, I already brought stuff that we're doing this this night. And I'm like, oh, okay. We had two hello, fresh nights and a takeout night. And then I said we bring our own breakfast and lunch and snacks. Done. Done. This was one of the first emails you sent to me when we were going to go on our writer's retreat. It wasn't about our work. No, no, no, no, no. It was about the meals. Let's plan our food. And then we'll come up with a work plan. I mean, I can't work on an empty stomach. I cannot. Well, one of the first things on Pam's list is let's just start small. Let's get you dressed, Michael. Yeah. And then there's that moment where he sits in the chair across from her and his robe opens up. Go to season five bloopers
我们晚餐吃什么？你会说，我已经带了东西，我们这天晚上吃这个。然后我说，哦，好吧。我们有两个Hello Fresh之夜和一个外卖之夜。然后我说我们自带早餐、午餐和零食。搞定。搞定。这是你发给我的第一批邮件之一，当时我们要去参加作家静修会。那不是关于我们的工作。不，不，不，不，不。那是关于餐食的。让我们计划一下我们的食物。然后我们再制定工作计划。我是说，我不能空着肚子工作。我不能。好吧，帕姆清单上的第一件事就是从小事做起。让我们先帮你穿好衣服，迈克尔。是的。然后就是那一刻，他坐在她对面的椅子上，他的长袍敞开了。去YouTube上看第五季的NG片段吧
on YouTube. Jenna, I don't even know how you salvaged anything from that scene. Matt Stone even talked about it in the DVD commentary. He was like, Jenna kept breaking up. She laughed every time. So Steve was wearing underwear. He was. He was not nude. They were like flesh toned, right? Yes, exactly. But on the day we had this idea that Pam would keep talking to him, but she would just move her little clipboard up so that she wouldn't have to see him. His business. Yes. But every time I did the gesture to move my clipboard up, it would make me laugh. Like the idea of it, all of it, it was one of those moments where I couldn't stay focused because I could see it from the outside and it was just so tickled me. It was such a funny moment. And Steve never broke.
珍娜，我甚至不知道你是怎么从那个场景中挽救出任何东西的。马特·索恩甚至在DVD评论中谈到了这一点。他说，珍娜一直在笑场。她每次都笑。所以史蒂夫穿了内衣。他穿了。他没有裸体。它们是肉色的，对吧？是的，没错。但在拍摄当天，我们有个想法，帕姆会一直跟他说话，但她会把她的小剪贴板举起来，这样她就不用看到他。他的私处。是的。但每次我做举起剪贴板的动作时，它都会让我发笑。就像那个想法，所有的一切，那是那种我无法保持专注的时刻之一，因为我能从外面看到它，它真的让我觉得太好笑了。那是一个非常有趣的时刻。而史蒂夫从来没有笑场。
Steve could just keep a straight face. And then I would get to a point where I couldn't go on and they'd be like, okay, cut. But Steve would just be like, what? Well, what is it? I was going to play the blooper. But when I rewatched it, Jenna, you're laughing so hard, you're making no sound. I know. So if I played it, it'd just be like, yes, it's true. While we're in this moment, I would love to point out some stuff in the background. Please. There is a shelf of dundies behind Michael during the scene. Also, you probably noticed all of the inspirational posters all over the condo. I did count though, 10 dundies. Let me know if you guys got the same amount, 10 dundies, plus a no right turn, no left turn and no U turn sign. Oh, during the scene. Okay. Well, I don't know if you noticed
史蒂夫总是能保持严肃的表情。然后我会达到一个无法继续下去的地步，他们就会说，好吧，卡掉。但史蒂夫只会说，什么？嗯，怎么了？我本来想播放那个NG片段。但当我重温它时，珍娜，你笑得太厉害了，一点声音都没有发出来。我知道。所以如果我播放它，它只会像这样，是的，是真的。在我们处于这个时刻时，我很想指出背景中的一些东西。请吧。在这个场景中，迈克尔身后有一个放着邓迪奖杯的架子。另外，你可能注意到了公寓里到处都是励志海报。我数了一下，有10个邓迪奖杯。如果你们数出的数量一样，请告诉我，10个邓迪奖杯，加上一个禁止右转、禁止左转和禁止掉头的标志。哦，在那个场景里。好吧，我不知道你有没有注意到
this. I did not notice it at first. But luckily, Floor H wrote in to say, there are two television sets in Michael's condo. Well, there's a big box one. And then there's the little one. Yes. So you can really see it at seven minutes, 29 seconds. He has bought himself a new TV, but he has not taken down the broken plasma. So it's like the new television is sitting on a TV stand. It's your standard square TV. It's much bigger, by the way, than the little mounted one on the wall. Yes. And it sits right under that broken one. But here's the thing. Michael is actually going to come up with some good ideas for today. He says they should assemble a dream team starting with Vikram. Yeah. He was the best seller at the telemarketing company. Pam's like, oh, okay.
这一点。我起初没有注意到。但幸运的是，弗洛尔·H写信来说，迈克尔的公寓里有两台电视机。嗯，有一个大箱式电视。然后还有一个小的。是的。所以你真的可以在7分29秒时看到它。他给自己买了一台新电视，但他没有把那台坏掉的等离子电视拆下来。所以就像新电视放在电视柜上一样。那是你标准的方形电视。顺便说一句，它比墙上挂着的小电视大得多。是的。它就坐在那台坏掉的电视下面。但问题是，迈克尔实际上要为今天想出一些好主意。他说他们应该组建一个梦之队，从维克拉姆开始。是的。他是电话营销公司里最优秀的销售员。帕姆说，哦，好吧。
And he reveals that they're going to have a meeting with a potential investor. But first, but first we need to get Michael dressed. Well, back at the office, Andy has put on his computer sort of like a montage of soccer moments, right? Like a soccer photo slideshow. Exactly. Charles sees it. He loves soccer. Andy is clearly sucking up to Charles. I actually remember us talking about soccer and Idris plays soccer. Really? Yes. He's like a good soccer player. He like played growing up. He like played on like a soccer league on the weekend. So he actually knew a lot about soccer. Well, he's British football, football. Yes. What am I saying? Football. Jim has this talking head about how he's just never been a kiss up. You know,
然后他透露他们将与一位潜在投资者会面。但首先，但首先我们需要让迈克尔穿好衣服。好吧，回到办公室，安迪在他的电脑上放了一个类似足球时刻的蒙太奇，对吧？就像一个足球照片幻灯片。没错。查尔斯看到了。他喜欢足球。安迪显然是在拍查尔斯的马屁。我实际上记得我们谈论过足球，而伊德里斯会踢足球。真的吗？是的。他是个不错的足球运动员。他从小就踢球。他周末会在足球联盟里踢球。所以他实际上对足球了解很多。嗯，他是英国足球，足球。是的。我在说什么？足球。吉姆有这个谈话头，关于他从来都不是一个马屁精。你知道，
that's just not how he operates. And BJ talked a little bit about his own experience for this Jim Andy suck up storyline. Let's hear it. This was based in my mind on an experience when I felt I had too much integrity to kiss up in a situation where I really wanted to impress people and I saw everyone else kissing up and getting ahead. Man, I should just go up there, you know. So I like the idea of a guy who who does it who just says screw it. Like I'm going to do this because this is how you get ahead. And maybe I I'm being lazy by not kissing up. And then it comes back to bite him. But I liked a good guy like Jim deciding to do it. Interesting, right? I just love that BJ takes moments like that and then puts it into his episodes. No, he reflects on things in
那不是他的行事风格。而BJ谈到了一点他自己对于吉姆拍安迪马屁这个故事情节的经历。让我们听听。在我看来，这是基于一种经历，当时我觉得自己太有原则了，在我想给别人留下深刻印象的情况下，我无法去拍马屁，但我看到其他人都在拍马屁并获得晋升。天哪，我应该直接上去，你知道。所以我喜欢这样一个人的想法，他做了这件事，他只是说去他的。就像我要这样做，因为这就是你获得晋升的方式。也许我不拍马屁是因为我懒。然后它反过来咬了他一口。但我喜欢像吉姆这样的好人决定这样做。很有趣，对吧？我只是喜欢BJ抓住这样的时刻，然后把它放进他的剧集里。不，他反思了
the moment and they stay with him. He's a very thoughtful person in that way. Yeah. Well, Jim is going to suck up by pretending like he played soccer or is a soccer player. I know there's this moment where he's like, I'm not going to do it. I'm not going to do it. And then he just succumbs and was like, yeah, I'm a player. And Dwight could not be happier. He's like, oh, really, Jim? I have never heard you talk about soccer. And he's like, you should play Charles, the two of you, today. And Charles is all about it. He's like, yes, I would love it. And Charles's whole demeanor changes toward Jim, toward everyone in the office. He's this very sort of smiley guy all of a sudden. Yeah. It's a big difference. Well, now Jim's going to be in a big pickle. He said,
当下的事情，它们留在了他心里。他在那方面是一个非常体贴的人。是的。好吧，吉姆要通过假装他踢足球或是一名足球运动员来拍马屁。我知道有那一刻，他说，我不会那样做的。我不会那样做的。然后他只是屈服了，说，是的，我是一名球员。而德怀特再高兴不过了。他说，哦，真的吗，吉姆？我从来没听你谈论过足球。他说，你今天应该和查尔斯一起踢球，你们两个。而查尔斯对此非常热衷。他说，是的，我很乐意。而查尔斯对吉姆、对办公室里每个人的整个态度都变了。他突然变成了一个非常爱笑的人。是的。这是一个很大的不同。好吧，现在吉姆要陷入大麻烦了。他说，
he played soccer from second to fourth grade. He was on the orange team. I love that talking head. I do too. It made me laugh. Well, listen, I think we should take a break because in the second half of the episode, we are going to see this dream team get assembled and we're going to see Jim have to deal with his soccer promise. It's good stuff. All right. We are back. And you guys, the dream team got Vikram. We got him. Vikram played by the awesome Ranjit Choudhury. He was so fun to work with. You know, he passed away last year. I know. He was so funny. We're in the car and, you know, Michael's all excited. They pull up to the bowling alley. Michael's like, I have to use the bathroom. And Vikram has this line. It's so good where he
他从二年级到四年级踢足球。他在橙队。我喜欢那个谈话头。我也喜欢。它让我笑了。好吧，听着，我觉得我们应该休息一下，因为在这一集的后半部分，我们将看到这个梦之队组建起来，我们将看到吉姆不得不处理他的足球承诺。这是好东西。好了。我们回来了。伙计们，梦之队得到了维克拉姆。我们得到了他。维克拉姆由出色的兰吉特·乔杜里扮演。和他一起工作太有趣了。你知道，他去年去世了。我知道。他太搞笑了。我们在车里，你知道，迈克尔非常兴奋。他们把车停在保龄球馆。迈克尔说，我得去洗手间。而维克拉姆有这句台词。太棒了，他在
says, confidence. It's the food of the wise man, but the liquor of the fool. I was so struck by this when I watched this episode. Me too. So I Googled it because I thought, is that like an old, I don't know, expression, proverb, like a Greek philosopher. No, it's nowhere. There are Reddit threads dedicated to trying to figure out where this line came from. There was an article written about this one line. You're kidding. And how wise it is and how the writer of the article couldn't find its origin either. Someone on our writing staff wrote that line. And we don't know who? I asked BJ. I asked Mindy. I asked Aaron Scher. No one can take credit for it. Aaron Scher said something that I really liked. He said, I don't know. Let's give credit to the whole writing
说，自信。它是智者的食物，却是愚者的烈酒。当我观看这一集时，我被这句话深深打动了。我也是。所以我谷歌了一下，因为我在想，那是不是什么古老的，我不知道，表达方式，谚语，像希腊哲学家说的。不，它哪儿都没有。有专门的Reddit帖子致力于弄清楚这句台词来自哪里。有一篇关于这一句台词的文章。你在开玩笑吧。它有多么明智，以及文章的作者也找不到它的出处。我们编剧组的某个人写了那句台词。我们不知道是谁？我问了BJ。我问了明迪。我问了亚伦·谢尔。没有人能居功。亚伦·谢尔说了一些我非常喜欢的话。他说，我不知道。让我们把功劳归给整个编剧
staff. Like some sort of collective genius came up with this line. But someone wrote that from the office. Really? And it's so good. And then last week, we talked about Vikram having this amazing talking head that got deleted. That got deleted. This is where it would have lived, you guys. Right after the scene in the car where he says this amazing proverb, he would have said, when you put your telemarketing career on the line, you're not putting much on the line. And Ranjit was just perfection. Everything, his delivery, I just, I couldn't get enough of him. Well, you just so believe him. And our guest actors were always that way. Alison Jones had this amazing ability to find people who didn't seem like they were acting at all.
组吧。就像某种集体天才想出了这句台词。但有人在《办公室》里写了它。真的吗？它太棒了。然后上周，我们谈到了维克拉姆有一个被删掉的精彩谈话头。那个被删掉了。这就是它本该存在的地方，伙计们。就在车里的那个场景之后，他说出这句精彩的谚语，他本该说，当你把你的电话营销生涯押上时，你并没有押上多少东西。而兰吉特简直是完美。一切，他的表达，我只是，我对他爱不释手。好吧，你就是那么相信他。而我们的客串演员总是那样。艾莉森·琼斯有一种惊人的能力，能找到那些看起来根本不像在演戏的人。
Yeah. Well, Michael is going to go into the bowling alley. He wants a pair of nine shoes. Guess who's working the counter? Ryan. Ryan, who's not on the list. You know, Vikram has this great line in the car where he's like, he's been gone a long time. Is it possible he went bowling? You know him better than I do. And I thought, Jenna, your delivery is Pam was so great when you're like, yeah. Yeah. So Pam goes in and sees what's happening and says this was not on the list, Michael. And then she looks at the list and then she's like, when did you put this on the list? I loved that. We noticed right away that Ryan is very tan and very blonde. I was really curious, when did BJ know he was going to have to do this with his hair?
是的。好吧，迈克尔要走进保龄球馆。他想要一双九号鞋。猜猜谁在柜台工作？瑞恩。瑞恩，他不在名单上。你知道，维克拉姆在车里有句很棒的台词，他说，他离开很久了。有没有可能他去打保龄球了？你比我更了解他。我想，珍娜，你的表达，帕姆太棒了，当你像那样说，是的。是的。所以帕姆走进去，看到了发生了什么，说这不在名单上，迈克尔。然后她看了看名单，然后她说，你什么时候把这个加到名单上的？我喜欢那个。我们立刻注意到瑞恩晒得很黑，头发很金。我真的很好奇，BJ什么时候知道他得用他的头发做这个？
This is what he said on the DVD commentary. So when I was in Germany and wasn't able to be on the show for a while, my character ran off to Thailand, all I knew about Ryan coming back was that he was going to be blonde. Now the tan. The tan is great, too. The tan is very funny. I heard of the hair as frosted tips. And then when we did it, Mindy, whose idea it was, came and was like, no, no, no, we're only going to go for this joke once you have to be completely blonde. And so we dyed it and I wore a hat in public for weeks trying to save the surprise and say, save my dignity. And he goes on to say that he was also touring stand up during this time. So he got a spray in brown coloring, you know that you could like, yeah. And so he sprayed
这是他在DVD评论中所说的。所以当我在德国，有一段时间不能参加节目时，我的角色跑到了泰国，关于瑞恩回来的唯一我知道的就是他会变成金发。现在晒黑了。晒黑也很棒。晒黑非常有趣。我听说头发是磨砂尖。然后当我们做的时候，明迪，她的主意，走过来，说，不，不，不，我们只会为了这个笑话做一次，你必须完全变成金发。所以我们把它染了，我在公共场合戴了几个星期的帽子，试图挽救惊喜，说，挽救我的尊严。他接着说，他在这段时间里也在巡回演出单口喜剧。所以他弄了一种棕色的喷雾染发剂，你知道那种你可以像，是的。所以他喷了
his hair brown and then he went on stage and it started coming off, like dripping off. Like what happened to Rudy Giuliani? Oh my God. Same thing. Yes, exactly. So he had to wear this hat, but it was like really stressful. He was trying to keep it a secret. I've used that spray for when my roots are coming in. It's genius. I love the spray, by the way. Yeah, it's great. But if you get really warm, it will sweat off. Yeah. Beware. Where are we? I'll give you a little location breakdown on the bowling alley. Idol Hour Lanes, which is the sign out sign, is a real bowling alley in Scranton. We matched their logo and in Scranton there's two and one of them is next to poor Richards. Yes, I've been to that
他的头发是棕色的，然后他上了台，它开始脱落，就像滴下来一样。就像鲁迪·朱利安尼发生了什么？天哪。同样的事情。是的，没错。所以他不得不戴上这顶帽子，但这真的很有压力。他试图保守秘密。我用过那种喷雾，当我的发根长出来的时候。它是天才。顺便说一句，我喜欢那种喷雾。是的，它很棒。但如果你真的很热，它会出汗掉。是的。小心。我们在哪？我会给你一个关于保龄球馆的小地点细分。Idol Hour Lanes，也就是外面的标志，是斯克兰顿一家真正的保龄球馆。我们匹配了他们的标志，在斯克兰顿有两个，其中一个就在Poor Richards旁边。是的，我去过那个
one. I thought you had. It's part of the bar kind of like when you go into poor Richards, you think at least I thought I was walking into a bar, but I actually was walking into a bowling alley and then the bar was to the right. It's interesting. I thought that we were at Pickwick Bowl, which does have a bar next to it, sort of similar to the real Idol Hour Lanes, but no. Randy Cordray said that we shot hours in Canoga Park. It was a bowling alley in Canoga Park. I also have a little guest star shout out to the bowling alley manager who calls Ryan a shoobitch. He was played by Jim Woods. He has appeared on How I Met Your Mother, Reno 911, and was a regular on the Comedy Satire Safety Geeks, S-V-I. Again, another person who did not seem like an actor to
一个。我以为你去过。它是酒吧的一部分，有点像当你走进Poor Richards时，你以为至少我以为我走进了一家酒吧，但我实际上走进了一家保龄球馆，然后酒吧在右边。很有趣。我以为我们在Pickwick Bowl，它旁边确实有一个酒吧，有点类似于真正的Idol Hour Lanes，但没有。兰迪·科德雷说我们在卡诺加公园拍了几个小时。那是卡诺加公园的一家保龄球馆。我还有一个小客串演员的呐喊，给那个称瑞恩为“鞋子婊子”的保龄球馆经理。他由吉姆·伍兹扮演。他曾出现在《老爸老妈浪漫史》、《雷诺911》，并且是喜剧讽刺剧《安全极客》(S-V-I)的常客。同样，又是一个看起来不像演员的人
me. Yeah. Seemed like a real grouchy bowling alley manager. Exactly. There was some delicious Pamsas because I mean, Pam just does not like Ryan. When he tells her he makes 60 grand a year and she's like, really? They pay you a yearly salary at the bowling alley? Yeah. So good. Well, the Dream Team is going to arrive to meet their investor. That's right. It's at what appears to be a nursing home. Can I tell you there was a beat in the script where Michael describes who the investor is? Okay. He says her name is Barbara Keevis. She invests in local businesses and I've been putting together a little presentation for her. Oh. But that didn't make it in the episode, but I'm like, okay, who's Barbara Keevis? I've got a location breakdown on where we shot this. Oh. Which is
对我来说。是的。看起来像个真正的脾气暴躁的保龄球馆经理。没错。有一些美味的帕姆时刻，因为我是说，帕姆就是不喜欢瑞恩。当他告诉她他一年挣6万块时，她说，真的吗？他们在保龄球馆给你发年薪？是的。太棒了。好吧，梦之队要到达去见他们的投资者了。没错。它看起来像是一家疗养院。我能告诉你吗，剧本里有一个节拍，迈克尔描述了投资者是谁？好吧。他说她的名字是芭芭拉·基维斯。她投资当地企业，我一直在为她准备一个小演示。哦。但这没能进入剧集，但我心想，好吧，芭芭拉·基维斯是谁？我有一个关于我们在哪里拍摄这个的地点细分。哦。这对我来说
interesting to me. It was a best Western hotel that was attached to the bowling alley and we redressed their conference room to look like a nursing home. Randy Cordray said that our location manager, Kyle Alexander, was really awesome that he would do this kind of thing all the time. If we had an episode that had two locations, he would somehow manage to find them right next to each other so that we could avoid having to do what they call a company move. Right. We have to move all the trailers, all the people, all the equipment. Save so much time and money. We were able to shoot the bowling alley and the nursing home all in one day. It saved so much money. It saved so much time and Randy was just giving a lot of compliments to Kyle saying that
很有趣。那是一家Best Western酒店，连接着保龄球馆，我们重新布置了他们的会议室，让它看起来像一家疗养院。兰迪·科德雷说我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大真的很棒，他总是做这种事。如果我们有一集有两个地点，他会以某种方式设法找到它们就在彼此旁边，这样我们就可以避免做他们所谓的公司搬迁。没错。我们必须搬动所有的拖车，所有的人，所有的设备。节省了这么多时间和金钱。我们能够在一天之内拍完保龄球馆和疗养院。它节省了这么多钱。它节省了这么多时间，而兰迪给了凯尔很多赞美，说
Kyle was able to do this all the time and it was a huge, huge benefit to our production. Amazing. And it was a benefit on a very practical level because it would save the time, which also wouldn't run down the crew as much. And it also made it so that the actors, we could flow from one experience sort of emotionally in the story and comedically right into another one. We didn't have to stop. It was awesome on many levels. Kyle, we love you. Thank you, Kyle. I want to point out right as the dream team is entering the retirement home at 12 minutes. Was it just me? Did anyone else notice the two retirement home employees wheeling someone in a blanket? I don't know. Was it a corpse under a blanket? Oh my God, I did not notice that. I mean, I went over and over to it
凯尔总是能做到这一点，这对我们的制作是一个巨大的，巨大的好处。太神奇了。而且它在非常实际的层面上是一个好处，因为它会节省时间，这也不会让剧组那么累。而且它还使得演员们，我们可以从故事中的一种情感体验和喜剧体验流畅地进入另一种。我们不必停下来。它在很多层面上都很棒。凯尔，我们爱你。谢谢你，凯尔。我想指出，就在梦之队在12分钟进入养老院时。是我一个人吗？还有其他人注意到那两个养老院员工推着一个裹着毯子的人吗？我不知道。毯子下面是尸体吗？天哪，我没注意到。我是说，我一遍又一遍地看它
just like, I couldn't stop looking at it. I was like, who is this back there? I'm going to show you, Jenna. It's so brief. But look, I don't know. This person's like on a cot or a stretcher. Do you see? Yes. I'll put it in stories. My other background catch for this scene is at 12 minutes, 27 seconds, the elderly gentleman that Michael is like snapping like, Hey, hey, over here. He is watching Maury Povich. Yes. And it's actually Maury Povich. That was scripted that he was watching Maury Povich. And they were able to get the rights to it. Yes. And on the screen, if you zoom in, there's a woman and there's a Chiron underneath her with like writing. Yeah. This is what it said. Tell the truth. Is my fiance in love with my mom? Oh, that's what they were watching.
就像，我无法停止看它。我在想，后面那个人是谁？我会给你看的，珍娜。它太短暂了。但看，我不知道。这个人就像在担架或担架上。你看到了吗？是的。我会把它放在故事里。我这一场景的另一个背景捕捉是在12分27秒，迈克尔像那样拍打的老绅士，嘿，嘿，这边。他正在看莫里·波维奇。是的。而且那确实是莫里·波维奇。剧本里写着他在看莫里·波维奇。他们能够获得版权。是的。而在屏幕上，如果你放大，有一个女人，她下面有一个带有文字的字幕。是的。这就是它说的。说实话。我的未婚夫爱上我妈妈了吗？哦，那就是他们在看的。
Okay. Well, Michael is going to make his pitch to this investment club. And it's a real club. There's three people, two women and the man who's watching Maury. But Pam and Ryan realized very quickly that one of the women is Michael's Nana. Yeah. It's not just Barbara Keevis. It's Nana. It's Nana. During this pitch, he's going to start by introducing his team. B.J. said he loved that he got the title in the episode. Oh, yeah. That's always kind of a fun thing when that happens. So Michael's like, Ladies and gentlemen, I present to you the dream team. Did you notice at 13 minutes 20 seconds when Michael is introducing Ryan that he winks at Nana while eating vanilla pudding in like a flirty way and Nana is delighted. I mean, he's buttering her up in the best way.
好吧。好吧，迈克尔要向这个投资俱乐部推销他的想法。这是一个真正的俱乐部。有三个人，两个女人和那个正在看莫里的男人。但帕姆和瑞恩很快意识到其中一个女人是迈克尔的奶奶。是的。不仅仅是芭芭拉·基维斯。是奶奶。是奶奶。在这次推销中，他将从介绍他的团队开始。BJ说他喜欢他在这一集中获得标题。哦，是的。当这种情况发生时，总是很有趣。所以迈克尔说，女士们，先生们，我向你们介绍梦之队。你注意到在13分20秒，当迈克尔介绍瑞恩时，他一边吃着香草布丁，一边向奶奶眨眼，以一种调情的方式，而奶奶很高兴。我是说，他正在以最好的方式讨好她。
Ryan is a hot mess. B.J. said, by the way, that he ate a ton of vanilla pudding and that it was delicious. I love a vanilla pudding. I also want to point out that at 13 minutes 41 seconds, there is a big zit on my jawline. No. This is the only time you see it because at 14 minutes 46 seconds, the zit is gone. So clearly, I got a touch up. Only you would notice that. I did not notice that. It's so large. It's one of those undergrounders that is, you know, had its own heartbeat. Yeah. And I would get those on my jawline. But thank you Laverne for covering that up by 14 minutes 46 seconds. And by the way, I can imagine, because they almost never let us get touch ups after we started rolling, I can imagine Laverne sitting at the monitors and just being
瑞恩是个烂摊子。顺便说一句，BJ说他吃了一吨香草布丁，而且它很美味。我喜欢香草布丁。我还想指出，在13分41秒，我的下颌线上有一个大痘痘。不。这是你唯一一次看到它，因为在14分46秒，痘痘不见了。所以显然，我得到了修补。只有你会注意到这一点。我没注意到。它太大了。它是那种有自己心跳的地下痘痘之一。是的。我会在我的下颌线上长那些。但谢谢拉弗恩在14分46秒把它遮住了。顺便说一句，我可以想象，因为他们几乎从不让我们在开始拍摄后进行修补，我可以想象拉弗恩坐在监视器前，只是
like, you need to let me get in there. You need to let me get in there. And so she probably convinced them and she was able to come in and touch up my zit. But you do see it at 13 minutes 41 seconds. Do you know what was super embarrassing? And this would happen every once in a while. What is when like someone like Matt, so on camera operator would be like, you would hear him sort of radio. Hey, Laverne, why don't you why don't you step in? It's because he is looking at it through the camera. That's true. That happened to me. That happened to me one time. I definitely had like one big one on my forehead and Matt was like, I think we should get a little powder for you. I'm like, Oh my God, Matt.
像，你需要让我进去。你需要让我进去。所以她可能说服了他们，她能够进来修补我的痘痘。但你确实在13分41秒看到了它。你知道什么超级尴尬吗？这偶尔会发生。是什么，当像马特这样的人，所以摄像机操作员会像，你会听到他某种无线电。嘿，拉弗恩，你为什么不，你为什么不介入？这是因为他正在通过摄像机看着它。那是真的。那发生在我身上。那有一次发生在我身上。我的前额上确实有一个大的，马特说，我想我们应该为你弄点粉。我说，天哪，马特。
Well, have you know the woman in this investment group who wants to give Michael the money was played by Eve Seagal. Eve has appeared in Shameless Superstar dead to me in the Legion. I was not able to figure out who played the gentleman. It was a non speaking role. So he was a background performer. So he is uncredited as far as I can find. But you know, in the end, Nana is going to say no. Nana says, this is an investment club. We're not about handouts here. And so she's a no. In the car ride, leaving there, Vikram made me laugh because he's like, Nana brought up some good points. I know. And then he's like, what kind of name is Nana? And Pam's like, it means grandmother. And then Vikram is like, I'm out. He's like sweet. Goodbye.
好吧，你知道这个投资小组里想给迈克尔钱的女人是由伊芙·西格尔扮演的。伊芙曾出现在《无耻之徒》、《超级明星》、《死于我手》和《军团》中。我没能弄清楚是谁扮演了那位绅士。那是一个没有台词的角色。所以他是一名背景表演者。所以据我所知，他是未署名的。但你知道，最后，奶奶要说不。奶奶说，这是一个投资俱乐部。我们这里不搞施舍。所以她拒绝了。在离开那里的车程中，维克拉姆让我笑了，因为他说，奶奶提出了一些很好的观点。我知道。然后他说，奶奶是什么名字？帕姆说，它意味着祖母。然后维克拉姆说，我退出了。他说甜。再见。
At Dunder Mifflin, the soccer game is about to be underway. There was a deleted Dwight talking head. He is setting up the whole parking lot. He's drawing chalk. I wondered how it got there. Yeah, the cones. There's a talking head while Dwight's doing this. And he shares one of his childhood dreams. Can we hear that? When I was a child, I always dreamed of being a referee, penalizing people, enforcing the rules. But I never could have dreamed of this. Wow. He would have been a great referee, actually. Yeah. Very quickly, we see that the group of Dunder Mifflin employees, they don't know anything about soccer. In the deleted scenes, there was a moment where Creed picks up the soccer ball and throws it at Kelly's back
在邓德·米夫林，足球比赛即将开始。有一个被删掉的德怀特谈话头。他正在布置整个停车场。他在画粉笔。我想知道它是怎么到那里的。是的，锥体。当德怀特做这件事时，有一个谈话头。他分享了他童年的梦想之一。我们能听听那个吗？当我还是个孩子的时候，我总是梦想成为一名裁判，惩罚人们，执行规则。但我从来没梦想过这个。哇。他实际上会成为一名出色的裁判。是的。很快，我们看到邓德·米夫林的员工群体，他们对足球一无所知。在被删掉的场景中，有一个时刻，克里德捡起足球，扔向凯利的背部
like dodgeball. And he's like, you're out. Oh, well, this is interesting because we got a piece of mail from Kyle T who wanted to know how long did you guys have to play soccer? Did you have any training or did they just let you guys go crazy? Was any of it choreographed? You were there. I mean, obviously the stunt that's coming up was choreographed, but the other stuff, was it just kind of freeform? Yeah, we could just sort of like fart around in the background. Okay. I did ask for sneakers. So I'm in sneakers. I thought Angela Martin might have taken it very seriously. Sure. So I'm in my sneakers. And then I actually caught a moment in the background that I kind of vaguely remember because it was that art imitating life, life imitating art, whatever.
就像躲避球。他说，你出局了。哦，好吧，这很有趣，因为我们收到了凯尔·T的一封邮件，他想知道你们必须踢多久的足球？你们有任何训练吗，还是他们只是让你们疯狂？有任何编排吗？你在那里。我是说，显然即将到来的特技是编排好的，但其他东西，只是某种自由形式吗？是的，我们可以在背景里胡闹。好吧。我确实要了运动鞋。所以我穿着运动鞋。然后我实际上在背景中捕捉到了一个时刻，我有点模糊地记得，因为那是艺术模仿生活，生活模仿艺术，无论什么。
Phyllis actually did get hit with the ball. What? When we were just horsing around. And you can see it? It's very subtle in the background. Hit where? I think up in her upper torso. Not hard, right? But that we were kicking around back there. If you go to 19 minutes, 28 seconds, tell me what you see. It was Creed. Creed, which is no surprise to me because Creed would sometimes get a little crazy with props. So I did a slow motion screen play by play that I will put in our stories. If my memory is correct, it didn't hurt hurt, but she did get hit with the soccer ball and we were like, oh my gosh. Okay. So here's the beginning of the ball. Uh-huh. Okay. Coming from Creed. Yep. Okay. Wow. It's high up. Next frame. See where it's headed? Right to her face. I know Phyllis
菲利斯确实被球击中了。什么？当我们只是在胡闹时。你能看到它吗？它在背景中非常微妙。击中哪里？我想是在她的上躯干。不重，对吧？但我们在后面踢球。如果你去19分28秒，告诉我你看到了什么。是克里德。克里德，这对我来说并不奇怪，因为克里德有时会用道具变得有点疯狂。所以我做了一个慢动作屏幕逐帧分析，我会把它放在我们的故事里。如果我的记忆没错，它没有伤到，但她确实被足球击中了，我们当时想，天哪。好吧。所以这是球的开始。嗯哼。好吧。来自克里德。是的。好吧。哇。它很高。下一帧。看到它要去哪里了吗？直接对着她的脸。我知道菲利斯
in the red sweater. Ironically. Then you kind of see her bending over. And then here. I see what looks like some people running to her aid. Yeah. Ed, you see the ball sort of hitting right there? Yeah. In her red. It looks like her shoulder maybe. There it makes contact. And then here you kind of see her face. Yeah. Like she's kind of bending to the side. So yeah. Oh my gosh. Phyllis did get hit with the ball in the episode where she gets hit with the ball. Yes. And so did Kelly. A lot of people were getting hit with the ball. Oh my gosh. Well, we did also get some fan mail. People wanted to know, did Phyllis perform her own stunt? Now, this is totally separate, guys. You know, what I just showed you was not a scripted moment. Here's what happens. There's this moment
穿着红毛衣。讽刺的是。然后你有点看到她弯下腰。然后在这里。我看到看起来像有些人跑去帮助她。是的。埃德，你看到球有点击中那里了吗？是的。在她的红色里。看起来可能是她的肩膀。在那里它接触了。然后在这里你有点看到她的脸。是的。就像她有点向侧面弯曲。所以是的。天哪。菲利斯确实在这一集中被球击中了，她被球击中了。是的。凯利也是。很多人被球击中了。天哪。好吧，我们也确实收到了一些粉丝邮件。人们想知道，菲利斯表演了她自己的特技吗？现在，这完全是分开的，伙计们。你知道，我刚才给你们看的不是一个有剧本的时刻。这是发生的事情。有这个时刻
where Charles is gonna kick the ball super hard toward Jim and Jim ducks and Phyllis gets clocked in the face. And everybody is like, Jim, why did you duck? Yeah. Dwight's like, Jim, why did you duck? An experienced soccer player wouldn't duck. First of all, I will tell you that there was no soccer ball used in this particular shot. Idris was kicking air and Phyllis faked getting hit. It is an amazing, fakey hit. Yes. Randy Cordray told me that we added the soccer ball using CGI magic. It was the folks at Stargate International. Randy actually said, I dare say it's one of the most effective uses of CGI that the office ever incorporated. I mean, it looks totally real. Big applause to John for his like, fakey seeing of the ball
查尔斯要用力把球踢向吉姆，吉姆躲开了，菲利斯被击中了脸。每个人都像，吉姆，你为什么要躲？是的。德怀特说，吉姆，你为什么要躲？一个有经验的足球运动员不会躲。首先，我会告诉你们，在这个特定的镜头中没有使用足球。伊德里斯在踢空气，菲利斯假装被击中。这是一个惊人的，虚假的击中。是的。兰迪·科德雷告诉我，我们使用CGI魔法添加了足球。那是Stargate International的人。兰迪实际上说，我敢说这是《办公室》曾经采用的最有效的CGI使用之一。我是说，它看起来完全真实。为约翰的像，虚假的看到球
and ducking. All of it. It all works. And then Phyllis is like, I think I swallowed a crown. I know. We also got a fan mail flurry. What about? Jim ducking. Oh, is this a soccer fan mail flurry, like soccer knowledge? Yeah, people coming to Jim's defense. Oh. So Ashley T said, I don't understand how Jim got blamed for this soccer ball hitting Phyllis in the face. Charles is the one who kicked it. It's clearly Charles' fault because I would have ducked too. Joseph F said, listen, I get it that maybe an experienced soccer player shouldn't have ducked that they should have jumped up and intercepted the ball with their chest. Yeah. However, Charles crossed the ball toward the side, in which case Jim and any other professional player
和躲避。所有的一切。它都有效。然后菲利斯说，我想我吞下了一个牙冠。我知道。我们也收到了一阵粉丝邮件。关于什么？吉姆躲避。哦，这是一阵足球粉丝邮件，就像足球知识？是的，人们为吉姆辩护。哦。所以阿什利·T说，我不明白吉姆怎么会被指责为这个足球击中菲利斯的脸。查尔斯是踢球的人。这显然是查尔斯的错，因为我也会躲。约瑟夫·F说，听着，我明白也许一个有经验的足球运动员不应该躲，他们应该跳起来用胸部拦截球。是的。然而，查尔斯把球传向侧面，在这种情况下，吉姆和任何其他职业球员
would have ducked. Really? Because then the ball goes out. I guess so. Yeah. So a fan mail flurry, lots of people commenting that Jim was not wrong for ducking. I do not know enough about soccer to comment. I don't either, even though I live on a soccer field every single Saturday with our kids, like we're always there. And my husband played soccer and he's coaching soccer. I should have asked Josh about it. Lee is coaching both of our kids' soccer teams this year. I know both of our husbands are soccer coaches this year. Yeah. And I just sit there and I'm just trying to figure out off sides. I'll never figure it out. I don't get it. I'll never figure it out. I don't think the kids get it. No. The referees call it, I don't get it. I don't ever get it. I'm like,
都会躲。真的吗？因为那样球就出界了。我想是吧。是的。所以一阵粉丝邮件，很多人评论说吉姆躲避并没有错。我对足球了解不够，无法评论。我也不了解，尽管我每个星期六都和我们的孩子生活在足球场上，就像我们总是在那里。而我丈夫踢足球，他在教足球。我本该问问乔什关于它的。李今年在教我们两个孩子的足球队。我知道我们两个丈夫今年都是足球教练。是的。而我只是坐在那里，我只是试图弄清楚越位。我永远弄不清楚。我不明白。我永远弄不清楚。我不认为孩子们明白。不。裁判判罚它，我不明白。我从来不明白。我心想，
what happened off sides? What? Listen, I've said in this episode that I don't know much about basketball. That's true. I don't know a lot about soccer. But talk to me about hockey, football, or baseball. You're very well versed in hockey. I don't get hockey. I've been into those sports. A live hockey game, there's nothing like it. I think it's the best sport to watch live. Personally, I know people love watching basketball live. I mean, watching basketball live, especially if you can get close to the court, it's like an amazing game live. I just love the whole hockey community. I love everything about it. I went one time and met some of your hockey mom friends. Yeah. And what I didn't know you guys is that hockey games, they serve beer at 10 in the morning.
发生了什么越位？什么？听着，我在这一集中说过，我对篮球了解不多。那是真的。我对足球了解不多。但跟我谈谈曲棍球、橄榄球或棒球。你在曲棍球方面非常精通。我不明白曲棍球。我一直喜欢那些运动。一场现场曲棍球比赛，没有什么比得上它。我认为它是现场观看最好的运动。就我个人而言，我知道人们喜欢现场观看篮球。我是说，现场观看篮球，特别是如果你能靠近球场，那是一场现场观看的精彩比赛。我只是喜欢整个曲棍球社区。我喜欢关于它的一切。我有一次去看了，见了一些你的曲棍球妈妈朋友。是的。而我不知道的是，伙计们，曲棍球比赛，他们在早上10点供应啤酒。
They do. I was like, oh my gosh. They sure do. We have like juice boxes at soccer. I remember going to like one of our early hockey games for my son and it was at 7.30 in the morning and I brought a coffee and people were like, does anyone want a beer from the concessions? And I was like, I don't think so, but thank you. Pretty amazing. Well, listen, the Dream team has lost a member and they get back to Michael's condo. Ryan's going to run inside. He wants to watch the closer on TNT. Very important to him. Pam's upset. She can't get out of the car. Now, Pam's going to spiral. So guess what? It was not in the script that you stayed in the car. I remember. It was Jen Salata's idea and she fought for it to have Pam stay in the car during the
他们确实。我心想，天哪。他们确实供应。我们在足球比赛有果汁盒。我记得去参加我儿子的一场早期曲棍球比赛，是在早上7点半，我带了咖啡，人们问，有人想要特许经营店的啤酒吗？我说，我想不需要，但谢谢。相当神奇。好吧，听着，梦之队失去了一名成员，他们回到迈克尔的公寓。瑞恩要跑进去。他想在TNT上看结局。对他来说非常重要。帕姆很沮丧。她不能下车。现在，帕姆要失控了。所以猜猜怎么着？剧本里没有写你留在车里。我记得。那是珍·萨拉塔的主意，她争取让帕姆留在车里，在
scene. Yeah. I was supposed to get out of the car and then sort of the idea was lean against it. And part of that was because it would be really easy to stage it camera-wise. Yeah. Well, I loved her staying in the car and I love this shot at 16 minutes, 22 seconds when you see Pam in the side mirror and Michael standing next to the car. It's such a cool shot. I had to bring a lot of emotion to the scene. You had to see Pam be convinced by Michael and this is one of those moments when Michael becomes really good at being a boss. And he's so serious. He's like, listen kiddo. Yeah. You quit. I quit. So that's the truth. It was very easy to get emotional because to have Steve Carell say, listen kiddo. I mean, I know he wasn't much older than us,
场景中。是的。我本该下车，然后某种想法是靠在它上面。而这部分是因为在摄像机方面布置它会非常容易。是的。好吧，我喜欢她留在车里，我喜欢这个在16分22秒的镜头，当你看到后视镜里的帕姆和站在车旁的迈克尔。这是一个非常酷的镜头。我必须为这个场景带来很多情感。你必须看到帕姆被迈克尔说服，这是迈克尔变得非常擅长做老板的时刻之一。而且他非常严肃。他说，听着，孩子。是的。你辞职了。我辞职了。所以这是事实。很容易变得情绪化，因为让史蒂夫·卡瑞尔说，听着，孩子。我是说，我知道他并不比我们大多少，
but he did always have sort of like a wise fatherly. He was our mentor. Yeah. Like exactly. And so to have your mentor coach you, it felt real and it made me emotional. And we just really connected there in a real way and it was really sweet. I just love those Pam Michael moments that reminds me of when he came to her art show and he shows up for her. Yeah. And it was great. Well, next we're going to see Michael on the phone and he's asking Billy Merchant if he has any free office space anywhere because they can't work out of Michael's condo anymore. They're going to throw him out. They got a letter and Billy says, I got something for you. It's like a supply room maybe, but there's also like a shower. It's also back at the
但他确实总是有一种智慧的父亲般的感觉。他是我们的导师。是的。就像没错。所以让你的导师指导你，它感觉很真实，这让我很情绪化。我们只是在那里以一种真实的方式真正连接，这真的很甜。我只是喜欢那些帕姆和迈克尔的时刻，这让我想起他去参加她的艺术展，他为她出现。是的。而且这很棒。好吧，接下来我们要看到迈克尔在打电话，他问比利·默钱特他是否有任何空闲的办公空间，因为他们不能再在迈克尔的公寓里工作了。他们要赶他走。他们收到了一封信，比利说，我为你准备了一些东西。它可能像一个储藏室，但也有像淋浴间。它也在回到
Dunder Mifflin Scranton building. Yeah. I probably should have led with that. And that's exactly right. It's like a supply room closet, but the gang is like, I could work here. Yeah. They can see it. And it's really sweet because the episode ends with Michael adding Michael Scott paper company to the little board in the lobby and Pam's handing him the little letters. Matt Sohn shared that there was a take where instead of you guys already having the letters that you were taking the letters from other people's businesses names. Oh, yeah. I remember that. I remember that. Which is really funny to me. And there was a tag that didn't make it in the episode. Kevin is back at reception. The phone rings. Kevin answers it and he's able to transfer
邓德·米夫林斯克兰顿大楼。是的。我本该先说那个。而且那完全正确。它就像一个储藏室壁橱，但帮派说，我可以在这里工作。是的。他们能看到它。而且它真的很甜，因为这一集以迈克尔把迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司加到大厅的小板子上结束，而帕姆递给他小字母。马特·索恩分享说，有一个拍摄，你们不是已经有了字母，而是你们从别人的公司名字中拿走字母。哦，是的。我记得那个。我记得那个。这对我来说真的很有趣。有一个没能进入剧集的标签。凯文回到接待处。电话响了。凯文接了它，他能够转接
the call to Dwight successfully. He's so happy. He looks all cocky to camera. Charles comes out and says, Hey, Kevin, I need you to set up a conference call with David Wallace and the other branch managers in 10 minutes. I'll take it in the conference room. Kevin looks like he's going to crap his pants. He goes, you got it, boss. And then he runs out of the office and never comes back. I asked Brian, what was it like to be at the reception desk for that week? Because I noticed throughout the whole episode, he's in the background and he was doing what I had to do, which is being in the background a lot. And he did point out that just because you guys were in the corner, which is something you've talked about, you know, they would make you guys stand at the
电话给德怀特成功。他太高兴了。他看起来对摄像机很自大。查尔斯出来说，嘿，凯文，我需要你在10分钟内安排一个与大卫·华莱士和其他分公司经理的电话会议。我会在会议室接听。凯文看起来要拉裤子了。他说，没问题，老板。然后他跑出办公室，再也没回来。我问布莱恩，在那一周坐在接待台是什么感觉？因为我注意到在整集中，他在背景中，他正在做我必须做的事情，那就是在背景中很多。他确实指出，仅仅因为你们在角落里，这是你们谈论过的事情，你知道，他们会强迫你们站在
copier. So he was just happy he got to sit for his background work. I'm telling you, I stood for almost nine years. Yeah, I love that. Well, that was dream team. Next up is Michael Scott Paper Company. We're going to get busy in that little storage room. I can't wait. Me too. All right, have a great week, you guys. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial
复印机旁。所以他只是很高兴他能坐着做他的背景工作。我告诉你们，我站了将近九年。是的，我喜欢那个。好吧，那是梦之队。接下来是迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。我们要在那间小储藏室里忙碌起来。我等不及了。我也是。好吧，祝你们有一个愉快的一周，伙计们。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月
at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Stitcher Premium，使用代码，OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。